women used to take L's in peace okay
let's not pretend like our grandmothers
our mothers never took an l and dating
never never made a poor decision okay
but they were at least as shame and you
know there's something respectable about
shame there's something respectable
about it because at least you know you
can admit all right that wasn't the
right decision but I do I do feel I do
feel shame about it um but the problem
is in modern culture is that really not
only do women not feel shame we parade
our bad decisions and Market it to the
younger women as good decisions and this
is the problem is you know and we get so
much Flack for just calling water wet
the sky is blue and don't generally like
you know it's it's better to be
more pure